regardez les deux sur la tête ils
mettaient à farine après ça me casse les
deux allaient en 60 secondes vous devez
sortir
baptisé quelqu'un échanger vos
chaussures avec lui et revenir avec les
chaussures de la personne 60 secondes
c'est parti pour 5 100 euros c'est parti
tu peux te prendre des chaussettes
c'est hyper important c'est pour eux
même toit quand on compte encore aller
il est là on va voir valoir rimouski
bien 500 briguant comment ça se passe
quand vous n'êtes pas cédé un seul set
grâce à l'e mail en mail à tous et non
pas combien de temps dit que mairesse de
temps au travail avec une chaussure du
ratio amer sur du monsieur qui me dit
après sa baisse
[Musique]
combien de temps va ce monde à 20
secondes 4 secondes
15 secondes c'est gagné
[Applaudissements]
pour cent cinquante ont tu vas devoir et
quelqu'un va devoir relever le défi de
la tête du pâtissier dacquois la tête du
pâtissier c'est-à-dire convaincre une
personne de vous casser deux jeux et de
la farine sur la tête 60 secondes vas-y
jamais 0 pas des gens me appelez vite on
laissera cinq secondes de plus il
apparaît les madmoizelles gens subissent
pour faire gagner de l'argent aux
téléspectateurs quelques joueurs m'ont
cassé les deux sur la tête ils votaient
à farine après autopsie mais casser deux
niveaux mon plus gros match
converti à il est très fort et il est
très fort jean michel nahas et bien une
bonne chère
c'est un petit truc et c'est pas mal
c'est pour voir où aller faire un câlin
à une personne sans lui parler rester au
moins 10 secondes dans ses bras c'est le
free hug
tu choisis qui il avait le niveau c'est
bon elle a 60 secondes vous connais pas
quelqu'un de vraiment pro avec un et
éviter de traverser j'ai peur pour vous
quand vous traversez pour vale aux
jeunes de passe quand il est là quand on
travaille comme personne
avais tu dois y aller du fait que c'est
un truc bizarre allez en parler c'est
[Applaudissements]
plus vrai j'adore j'adore elle vient de
dire la bafa le 28 juin il faudra quand
même hein
c'est quand même énorme alors isabelle
morini-bosc revient à l'est où elle sait
qu'elle doit revenir au moins 60 jours
on discute elle dispute
merci bon on va dire que c'est gagné
[Musique]